-I'm very happy
to have you here.
-I'm really grateful that
you invited me.
-Now before you were
a senator...
-Yes.
-...you were a mayor.
-I was.
-And I would imagine that
once you become a senator,
all of a sudden,
the breadth of what you need
to know gets so much larger.
For example, a mayor of Newark
doesn't need to know
foreign policy.
-I had a lot of problems with my
International House of Pancakes.
-Yeah, exactly.
-[ Chuckles ] I did. I did.
-And so what was it like
when you first had
to sort of undertake
the learning about things
that are so important?
-I mean, you --
Even before I got in the office,
I called around
from literally active generals
to foreign policy experts.
But it's never like
the first time
you have to deal with
a real issue.
And I'll never forget,
the first time I was invited
to the situation room,
it was the --
Vice President Biden
was meeting with us.
And I was all awkward.
I think it was my first days,
literally, there.
And I'm excited this is --
I still can't believe I'm here.
-Yeah, you're a senator now.
You're in the situation room.
That's a big deal.
-It is a big deal.
My mom always says,
"behind every successful child
is an astonished parent." And --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And this is one of the moments
I'm astonished.
I'm -- I'm sitting there,
and the Vice President
is ridiculously late,
and we're all just sitting there
awkwardly -- awkwardly.
And it was one of
the best moments for me
because there's Al Franken,
and one of our other
Senate colleagues asked him,
"Well, who was ever the worst
guest on 'Saturday Night Live?'"
[ Laughter ]
And before you know it,
here I am sort of awkward,
sitting there,
intense and ready.
And Al Franken, who is one of
the more brilliant senators
in the United States Senate.
He's incredibly talented,
gifted.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But he -- but he's also
wickedly funny.
-Yeah. He likes to tell
a story, too.
-He had us -- He had me
literally fighting back
the tears,
laughing so hard
as I'm sitting there.
And then the Vice President
comes in, and we get going.
But look, it's -- it is,
regardless of what you think
about partisan politics,
whatever,
walking on to that Senate floor,
especially for me,
most Americans don't know,
we haven't had that many
African-Americans
that have served in the Senate.
I'm the fourth African-American
popularly elected into
the United States Senate.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So I never -- I never lose my
sense of gratitude to New Jersey
nor my sense of history
of what it means
to walk on that floor every day
that I do.
-You obviously
walk on that floor
with colleagues on both sides
of the aisle.
We mentioned earlier
in the show,
one of your colleagues,
Senator Bob Corker,
he is retiring.
And it seems like
when Senators retire --
don't take this personally --
they get a little bit
more honest.
-[ Laughs ]
-And so he used this opportunity
to say that Donald Trump,
you know, is adult daycare,
requiring of adult daycare,
that he might be starting
World War III.
When you hear those comments,
do you sort of nod your head
and say, "Oh,
that's what we're thinking
on this side of the aisle,"
or are you sort of shocked
that it's even happening?
-Well, first of all,
this isn't new to --
I mean, this is one
of the worst kept secrets
in Washington,
that Republicans and Democrats
are very worried about
the person that's...
-Mm-hmm.
-...sitting in the White House.
And literally,
during the confirma--
I mean, I voted against most
of Donald Trump's appointees.
You know, from --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, Jeff Sessions,
Pruitt, DeVos.
These are people that had me
really concerned.
But you've got a guy like
General Mattis,
and the conversations
surrounding that were,
"Let's make sure we put
the Secretary of Defense,
"somebody that we can all
rely on to try to be a bulwark,
a wall between
Donald Trump and disaster."
-It seems that's an unfair thing
to ask of the people
that keep getting mentioned
as the ones
who are supposed
to save us from danger.
Because it seems like being
the Secretary of Defense
or the Secretary of the State,
those jobs are hard enough
without also having to keep
an eye on the President
not, um...ruining everything
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, and obviously this is a
comedy show, but this really --
-Sometimes.
[ Laughter ]
-On a good night.
-In and out.
On a good night.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But I'm very concerned
right now.
I mean, we have crises all over
the planet Earth,
serious things.
We've lost some soldiers
last week in Niger.
And there are hot spots
from the Ukraine
to Syria to Nigeria.
I mean, you can go through
the challenges.
And we're in a really bad spot.
Not only have we had
our Secretary of State,
who should be
the leader of diplomacy,
but you have an administration
who has been
savagely cutting diplomacy,
even just funding
the kind of things that help
keep regions stable.
Donald Trump's willingness
to speak in a manner
about nuclear war, that is,
to me, terrifying, frankly,
about the consequences of
someone who decides
to conduct foreign policy
that way.
We -- And, I mean, when we --
I'm on the Foreign Relations
Committee with Senator Corker.
I've been grateful
for Senator Corker's leadership
in trying to keep us together
in a bipartisan way
to push back against
the White House.
So we have work to do.
This is not --
This is a very serious reality,
especially with
the important role
the United States has
been playing
in stabilizing regions with
high instability,
in dealing with
global terrorism.
We've been a very good leader,
and right now,
it seems that we're pulling back
and operating in a manner
that has our allies --
I just recently met
with some ambassadors
from various countries
that we're allied with.
This is a very perilous time,
and all Americans, not just
should be joking about it,
but we should be concerned
where -- in the state we are.
And I don't think patriotism,
right?
I would like to see people
on both sides of the aisle,
not just talking about this.
I think we all need to be doing
more about this.